so let's suppose you've been selected to
be in seven different festivals some of
which you may be able to attend some of
which you will not be able to go to what
are some of the things you should start
doing even if you can't go to them a
filmmaker should start doing to to
grease those wheels let them know
knowing you may want to come back in a
couple years things like that um okay
well the definitely what you want to do
when you get into a Film Festival is
again just be cool and be conscious of
the schedule you have to make a delivery
to them so you have to make so the first
thing you do is they'll usually they'll
tell you you're in first and then a day
later you'll get an email and they'll
say can you know please accept this
invitation they want to know you're in
you accept it then you get an email from
them with all their information like you
know thank you you've been
congratulations you've been acceptable
to tell you like when it is what they
provide in terms of airfare hotel if
anything about have to provide something
then talk about you know when materials
are do you know what materials are what
you score your screening on so really
you want to think about right away you
want to kind of put together a schedule
whereas we have to have our master to
them by this date and then you just kind
of master didn't need DCP did a blu-ray
HD cam I'm a V file whatever it is you
want to make sure you have that in your
mind and you also it's an automatic
thing where you want to create your
bonus material as you go okay well we
need to have posters and postcards and
so forth and then you wanna think about
whether or not going to go and if
they're paying for airfare and hotel
it's way easier to decide but if it's if
it's if it's at the same time as another
festival we had a case where we had
three at once like twice on the favorite
circuit so at that point you say well
you know who's gonna go am i you know
are my actors gonna go without me and
you do have if you have you know like on
favor we have two solid lead actors and
the film is the two of them pretty much
for the entire running time they're the
two leads the two character piece so and
they were both involved from even before
we're sort of shooting during the
writing process so it's easy for me to
say okay Patrick day you're gonna go to
this festival blame me you're gonna go
to this festival how many go to this
festival will divide and conquer
and every single festival gets some sort
of good representation of the movie they
get a you know someone who knows the
whole film the actor is less involved
with behind the scenes you know
obviously the writer director editor is
but they were there and they're on
camera and that's way cool for an
audience they see the active they just
saw on screen do a QA so figure out
who's gonna go and if you can get there
get there but favorite was only only one
festival this run no one was able to get
to which is pretty cool I think with
with official it was about 40 percent
we couldn't get anybody there it just
happens you know you just can't afford
to get it this time or it's this
conflict with something else but with
this we were very fortunate because we
had three people we could divide up and
send it four ways but so that's the
first thing you do is start thinking
about the deadlines you know and it's
work and also you know I always say
write to them ask them you know you know
knowledge everything great thank you so
keep it concise but acknowledge it take
it so much we'll have all the materials
to you there's anything else you can do
let me know if you have any special
things you can ask for or offer other
anything such things you can offer like
if you have we have you know this
special giveaway t-shirt package or let
them know about that right away and see
if they can use it if you're going to go
to the festival also write to them and
volunteer well you know happy to do
panels or you know whatever you need me
to do so they you know you're
contributing to their show and part of
being grateful and only the rare
instance that you can't make it life
gets in the way finances get in the way
right yeah finances again get in the way
what should you do maybe social media
wise or what can you do you know
virtually that could maybe make up for
some of that well whether you're there
or not you should do as my social media
as possible first of all find the
festivals Twitter handle Facebook
handles like them follow them usually
they'll follow you back or they'll find
you as well
yeah then if you have a website have a
shoot have a schedule a screening
schedule and linked a ticket link when
it becomes live - there
date time everything else everything you
would put on your postcard you can put
on your website including the link which
unlike a postcard is actually clickable
I have it updated all the time and yeah
I just always do social but you do
whether you're there or not I mean it
doesn't really change it it's more
effective if you're there even so if you
know three people live in Delaware and
you're the Delaware Film Festival the
odds of them showing up to your
screening are hundreds of times higher
if you're actually going to be there to
have a drink with afterwards if you're
not there you know it's just it's
difficult for the festival festivals
position is you know anybody can go see
the new Tom Cruise movie any time it's
playing thirty five shows a week in it
on every other screen all throughout the
city but if you want to see such and
such you got to come this one time
there's one screen or maybe two times if
it's you playing twice in a festival but
you know if this is exist are you not
going to see more anywhere else this is
new and exclusive them interesting and
different and any added value you can
add on to that event aspect really helps
the festival so you being there in
person it's a big deal I mean especially
in fin city in festivals that aren't
taking place in Los Angeles New York
where the isn't as common for filmmakers
just you know fall out of the sky and
talk about their film it's a big deal
I think it's a big deal for you as a
filmmaker to see your film with an
audience I don't watch the movie I watch
the audience watch the movie you learn a
lot and you've got a lot of people
talking about your film and the
questions they ask and and they're more
likely to remember you when they leave
because remember festivals is all about
audience building you know creating a
brand for your movie getting it out
there in front of audiences so that they
remember you when VOD or DVD happens
down the line do you see a lot of
filmmakers doing those things that
you've outlined I mean they're all
amazing tips and I think that you know
it's a cliche but a recipe for success
there we go okay so what do you see a
lot of people doing that I do see a lot
of filmmakers doing that you're funny
you meet the same people on the circuit
over and over and over I think you know
filmmakers in general when you've worked
for two or three or four or five years
on your movie you're pretty I mean
you're pretty proud of it or at least
you're pretty proud of the
accomplishment or you or you want to
talk about it it's like you know you
want to go and blather about your stuff
and
and so getting in front of an audience
where they gonna talk about nothing but
your movie is pretty gratifying you know
even the occasional
oddball it goes off on a tangent about
something else in the audience which
this happened periodically but even then
I'm just getting out there and
glad-handing some people don't like it
though some people do I know they're shy
or their reclusive or they don't want to
talk about it or they they they don't
feel comfortable doing it but it is part
of the job it's why I have to call the
politician of right the politician role
of the filmmaker were you afraid to go
out yeah you go out you're glad hand you
like kiss babies and do all those things
and you got to keep a straight face
during Q&A sometimes I know it was
official rejection we screened in San
Diego and the very first screening we
had very first question the Q&A I opened
it up us anybody came any questions and
this kind of fern role in it's too long
like that and his wife is one and I kind
of just blame well sir not really a
question but thank you anybody else I
can use it you have to kind of smile and
move on from there without getting mad
or attacking your audience or you know
whatever else right heckling back yeah
heckling back you can't yeah you got to
be cool yeah you gotta respect okay I
didn't like your movie okay doesn't
happen actually usually if they don't
like it they're gonna leave and I've had
a so on it with the official rejection
so we got Denver someone keynote it was
a filmmaker who I guess program for
Sundance it was kind of offended by the
movie dad don't argue with it just like
okay you know hear him out it's hard to
do sometimes but but being a politician
is important for audience building it's
important for network building again if
you want to be on the circuit a second
third fourth time and not spend
thousands and thousands of dollars
getting your film out there going out
and glad-handing and you know bringing
the bring of staff pizza like the staff
it's working their asses off in that
office they haven't seen daylight for
weeks and when they do it someone
wanting something for them some don't
make her wanting to know why those
greeting was two minutes later something
like that so Denver stars we brought
them like a bunch of pies and they were
like oh my god I can't believe you
brought us pies and then I asked for a
fee waiver
what flavor were they they were rhubarb
for they pie no pizza so oh no our vat
Avilla pizza in Denver best pizza in the
city better than Bo Joe's we brought
them stacks of those
and they were very happy
you